So, you remember how we did panoramas?
We basically found interesting points
in an image, and we described them.
We built these descriptors,
these sift descriptors.
We found punitive matches, possible
matches between them, and then we did
something like RANSAC, or something like
that, in order to find the alignment.
Well, we can actually do something for
recognition that's related.
Now essentially
what we we're going to do is to say
we're going to do the same thing.
We're going to find interesting
points where these are sort of
highly repeatable points
that you'll find.
And what we're going to talk about
is describing the patches around
those points.
And then we're going to use the
collection of those described patches
as a way of generally characterizing
the image for recognition.
So, as we've talked about before,
each location in an image.
So here we have different
locations in an image, all right.
And a bunch of different
training images.
And each one of these
has a descriptor that,
in this what these curves are meant
to show is that they land somewhere
in feature space, so this they land
in the descriptor's feature space.
And you can imagine that you
get a collection of these, so
that there's a whole bunch of
descriptors in a given image.
And then we're going to make
the following assumption, and
we actually made this
assumption before right?
We assume that when we have
points that are sort of similar
in the descriptor space that they are or
nearby in the descriptor space,
that those patches are either the same
patch in a new image a similar patch.
So one way of thinking about this is
it's a way of just giving a description
of a little bit of local
content in the image.
And so now if I get a new
picture that comes in, right?
I can say let me find the patches in it.
And see if I find lots of
the same local patches that
were in my first image, and say,
okay, if I find a lot of those,
then I would know that maybe this
new picture is the same thing,
maybe same category or
same object, as the first picture.
The problem, of course,
is that any given picture can
have thousands of patches.
So a collection of different objects,
and different images.
There could be millions of these things.
And the problem is, if I come up with
a new image, and I find a patch in it.
I have this problem,
of possibly having to search over
millions of different patches.
I have to do something
a little more clever.